Donald Trump
imploded like a tantruming child pooping
in the sandbox so nobody else can play
in it
over the criminal referrals approved by
the House of Representatives committee
investigating the Trump Riots of January
6 2021. let's go right to the horse's
mouth for lack of a better term Donald
Trump starting with a statement let's
get this right on the screen properly
for you a statement on the January 6th
committee referral these folks don't get
it that when they come after me people
who love freedom rally around me it
strengthens me what doesn't kill me
makes me stronger Americans know that I
pushed for twenty thousand troops to
prevent violence on January 6th that is
a lie first Trump claimed he wanted 10
000 troops now he says it's 20. there's
no evidence that he ever made that
request and that I went on television
and told everyone to go home he did that
hours into the riots and still said the
rioters are Justified for being there
and being angry because the election was
stolen which it wasn't Trump continuing
think of it
the radical left Democrats communists
despite on my campaign that's a lie lied
to the fisa court that's a lie lied to
Congress many people have lied to
Congress it doesn't actually change the
reality of this and and of course when
Trump's people lied to Congress they all
said lying to Congress is no big deal
allowed an invasion of our country on
the southern border
policy has not substantively changed
since Trump underbiden On the Border
embarrassed Us in Afghanistan Biden did
the same thing Trump said he was going
to do gave away our energy Independence
we actually are more over producing
under Biden in terms of oil than we were
under Trump
killed us on job losing regulations
meaningless and vague wouldn't use the
ten thousand plus soldiers I recommended
for January 6th in his last truth he
said it was twenty thousand twelfth
Century the number changes uh refused to
look into election fraud the reason for
January 6th rigged and stole the 2020
election allowed ballot stuffing FBI
Facebook Twitter and Biden crime that's
just a mess that's just a word salad and
he continues continued from previous
truth and I'm the one that the corrupt
and partisan unselect committee goes
after a two-tiered quote justice system
and by the way
whatever happened with the massive
number of crimes committed by Joe and
Hunter Biden were unaware of any such
crimes as of right now they're right
there documented and 100 certain also
where's the prosecutor from Delaware
what happened to him is he friends with
the Ukrainian prosecutor who didn't
prosecute after Biden held up the
billion dollar payment to Ukraine I did
nothing wrong in all caps as you see
he's losing it then he starts retweeting
various videos propaganda videos
including one that refers to Adam's
Shifty shift
uh retweets a message from Elise
stefanic
posts a poll a video of Alan dershowitz
another video of Alan dershowitz
promotes Troth sensual
and then is just posting stuff on and on
and on and then picks it back up again
this morning with almost no delay files
conclusively revealed that the FBI
totally discredited damning and by the
way he spells damning the way a beaver
does you know beavers are damning stuff
it's just beyond parody
uh damning factual information from
Hunter Biden's laptop from hell it's
just on and on here it's only even
tangential and then he goes full
conspiracy
the so-called deep State often referred
to by many other names including
cheaters insurrectionists Communists and
yes even our good old rhinos have been
working on Sinister and evil plots for a
long time even well before I came to
office they are long-seeded swamp
creatures and are bad news for the USA
blah blah blah blah blah he then goes
after the committee that sent the
referrals I see where the unselect
committee using the Democrats favorite
weapon disinformation is trying to make
the case that I didn't really believe I
won the election that's a total lie I
never thought for even a moment that the
presidential election of 2020 was not
rigged and stolen and my conviction
became even stronger as time went by now
with all of the massive evidence that
has come to light including recently
with the FBI suppression of election
changing information I was 100 right
hours hours on Truth social truth
essential spreading lies and being
triggered now at the end of the day the
next step is up to the Department of
Justice is the Department of Justice is
Merrick Garland ready and willing to do
what we all know is supported by the
facts and that is what that is to charge
Donald Trump do I believe he will spend
a day in prison I still do not
but do I believe it would be the correct
thing to charge him I would because
that's a decision you make based on the
evidence let me know if you expect
charges against Donald Trump Friday
December 23rd we are doing our final
membership special of the Year
everyone's first month's payment will be
donated by us to an organization that
sends cash to people who really need it
and it will be doubled so hypothetical
okay memberships are six bucks a month
Friday we get you a coupon code saves
you fifty percent you pay three bucks we
donate the three bucks you still keep
the membership and we double the three
dollars with six we match the first
fifteen thousand dollars we've never
done this before
I want you to participate I want you to
be involved all you have to do is get on
my mailing list by signing up at
davidpackman.com the box to enter your
email is at the top right of the website
more on Friday very exciting quick break
be right back
I love reading I read every day no
matter how I arrange my schedule I never
have enough time to read all the books
that I want which is why blinkist has
been such an important part of my life
for years now our sponsor blinkist is
the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils them down into
an explainer that you can read or listen
to in just 15 minutes which includes all
the most important takeaways from the
book with blinkist I can absorb the
essence of 15 different books in an
afternoon so I can quickly gather
insights from all sorts of perspectives
make connections have those kind of aha
moments that don't happen so easily
which is why I feel enriched when I use
blinkist blinkist also summarizes
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers and with the
blinkist connect feature my girlfriend
and I can share one account share books
podcasts with each other talk about them
on the go and don't for forget blinkus
makes the perfect holiday gift my
audience can try blinkist free for seven
days and get 25 percent off after that
go to blinkist.com Pacman the link is
down below